guten tag herr schindler und vielen dank
dass sie die zeit haben um einmal diese
bilder mit uns einzuordnen
ich möchte sie vorweg einmal fragen wenn
sie also auf gelsenkirchen schauen dass
auf deutschen straßen scheiß juden
geschrieben wird was geht ihnen da als
ehemaliger sicherheits architekt dieses
landes was geht ihnen da durch den kopf
diese entwicklung der letzten tage
kiebel ist erschreckend und unerträglich
weil sie gegen die deutsche staatsräson
verstoßen das verbrennen von flatten
steinwürfe gegen synagogen
antisemitische hassparolen auf deutschem
boden sind mit unserer geschichte
einfach nicht vereinbar was sagt das
über deutschland aus dass junge menschen
gegen juden auf die straße gehen also in
einer völlig neuen generation
ja man muss natürlich abwarten was die
polizeilichen ermittlungen ergeben wer
das jetzt im einzelnen ist aber die
bisherigen erkenntnisse zeigen ja dass
es nicht nur um palästinenser geht
sondern dass wir menschen akteur aus dem
gesamten arabischen raum dort haben und
sie haben es ja schon angesprochen das
sieht man auch an den mitgeführten
flatten türkische flaggen turnierchef
latten und so weiter diese menschen
missachten unsere gastfreundschaft in
zweierlei hinsicht nämlich einerseits
indem sie straftaten begehen beleidigung
bedrohung aberkennung des existenzrechts
von israel und in zweiter hinsicht in
dem sie gegen unseren grund kommt
unseren gesellschafts politischen
grundkonsens verstoßen nämlich dass von
deutschem boden keine antisemitische
hetze stattfinden darf und das ist kein
kavaliersdelikt sondern das rührt an der
dna des deutschen staatsverständnisses
herr schindler ich kann mich an momente
aus den letzten wochen erinnern da ist
die polizei sehr entschlossen gegen
menschen vorgegangen die gegen korona
regeln verstoßen haben
teilweise gab es dann auch bilder wo ein
streifenwagen in hamburg einen
jugendlichen verfolgt hat oder in
münchen in parks dann plötzlich sich ja
die polizei auf leute
los gegen die feuer dort einfach
picknick gemacht hatten wenn man sich
jetzt an guckt das also 180
gewaltbereite junge männer und frauen
vor einer synagoge in stellung gehen
dort auch steine und flaschen dabei
haben und die polizei die schafft es
gerade noch so das gebäude zu sichern
aber gegen die menschen selbst geht sie
nicht vor
wie erklären sie sich dass und hätten
sie sich da vielleicht auch ein
stärkeres zeichen des rechtsstaats
gewünscht also ich glaube es ist immer
schwer vom wohnzimmer aus oder am
fernsehgerät die aktuelle lage vor ort
beurteilen zu wollen und in unsere
sicherheitsbehörden einmal aussprechen
ich glaube dass die polizeiführung aber
auch die landesämter für
verfassungsschutz und das bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz eine gute arbeit
leisten
denn eins muss man auch klar feststellen
die sicherheitsbehörden können nur an
den symptomen arbeiten aber die ursache
für diese grundproblematik ist ein
gesellschaftliches problem das alle
angehen müssen rechnen experten
befürchten ja angriffe auf juden aber
auch auf synagogen und es wird immer
wieder beteuert in deutschland das wir
juden schützen aber wie sieht das
tatsächlich aus schützen wir unsere
mitbürger ich bin ganz sicher dass die
konzepte zum schutz der jüdischen
einrichtungen sehr aktuell sind und
lageangepasst sind aber noch einmal es
geht nicht darum dass wir gute
schutzkonzepte haben sondern wir müssen
den antisemitismus begrenzen der in
unserer gesellschaft fuß gefasst hat und
wir dürfen natürlich den antisemitismus
der deutschen bevölkerung nicht
verharmlosen nicht kleinreden aber der
antisemitismus denen wir jetzt ja sehen
unter den migranten ist eine tatsache
der wir uns stellen müssen und das
beginnt damit und da bin ich ihnen sehr
dankbar dass wir diese tatsache offen
ansprechen
aber es gehört damit noch lange nicht
aus sondern wir müssen auch diejenigen
die unsere gastfreundschaft hier
missbrauchen
außer landes bringen
sie sagen ganz richtig wir müssen den
antisemitismus hier bei uns in unserer
bevölkerung bekämpfen haben sie da
lösungen wie würden sie diese thematik
anpacken
ja ich denke wir brauchen drei punkte
das eine ist wir brauchen eine bessere
integration dieser menschen sie sind nun
mal da und dann müssen wir uns auch um
sie kümmern da geht kein weg daran
vorbei und die die sich nicht helfen
lassen die müssen wir außer landes
verbringen
zweitens wir brauchen bessere bildung
insbesondere bessere erwachsenenbildung
und drittens sehe ich eine ganz große
verpflichtung bei den muslimischen
verbänden und organisationen und gerade
bei den muslimischen verbänden und
organisationen erwarte ich merke ich
viel mehr engagement
ich will es mal ganz konkret machen
gestern war freitag da finden die
freitagsgebete in den moscheen statt
für mich stellt sich die frage wie viel
prozent in wie viel prozent der
deutschen moscheen hat der imam dazu
aufgerufen nicht an anti israelischen
demonstrationen teilzunehmen
das würde mich einmal sehr interessieren
und ich sage noch mal ich sehe hier mehr
defizite als hoffnungsvolle ansätze
ja das sind natürlich ist eine
ernüchternde analyse
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren